this podcast and every other podcast I
make is brought to you by our supporters
on patreon this particular episode was
available on patreon early ad free and
as an extended version there's basically
an extra discussion at the start that I
didn't include on the YouTube version
though of course this is not going to be
the norm or anything you definitely do
not have to support but it means a lot
and it helps me create these unique sort
of Niche games industry podcasts that I
make so thank you so much if you do
support and if not check out the link in
the description Troy and Austin are
maybe joining us Troy said definitely
yes Austin said he'll try uh whatever
space folks oh Austin said I'll be there
shortly so I was going to ask you a
really boring question Mike because I
know we've spoken about it before but I
feel like everybody's talking about it
and I saw you tweet about it thus you
are implicated I don't know yeah I get
an AI to answer this question for me
yeah so the AI art topic has come back I
don't really know how it resurfaced I
think everyone's using from what I
understand people are using an app right
to make themselves look cool and I never
do that stuff because
I don't care I don't really know why I
have no justification I don't need to
because I look like this anyway I don't
need to be part of it because I'm like I
don't need to see more we're just myself
we're just I thought I was doing a joke
about being good looking but I like I
was taking it the opposite way I was
like I don't need any more I don't need
to see any more of them keep it away
that was your thought look at my face I
appreciate that that's great
like I don't know there's there's a lot
of like social media trends people do
where they like post a picture of
yourself a year ago and I'm like
it died it's the same just it's the same
my face is already available enough it's
I'm good
um
yeah
[ __ ] done five or eight dollars
you're paying to do that
oh my God the amount of money that that
app must be making is just
unfathomable I couldn't believe people
were paying for it and yeah artists can
be a lot more expensive than eight
dollars but you can pay artists on
Fiverr eight dollars to make you
something
um mind-blowing to to find out people
paying for it so I guess it's some sort
of app that you upload pictures of
yourself
and you pick again I haven't used it
don't know how it works you pick um a
scene or a circumstance and it will
create a version of you as a Roman or a
princess or a fairy or something
um
but of course as all apps like this one
do the way that it works is what it is
doing is pulling from other art on the
internet so it is doing a broad image
search and stealing pieces from other
art uh which
I don't imagine will remain legal like I
feel like does it count because it's
transformative
so it's fascinating legally like the the
conversations are happening right now
like in the in the commercial World
about this because because obviously
things will just be cheaper in the
theory
well yeah but like and also like there's
as a tool like so for example like
Photoshop has filters now just like you
can use AI to like sharpen images or uh
generate a depth map which is really
useful for various things in games like
there's lots of tech that's interesting
with this you can make control of
cyberpunk you can make the entirety of
cyberpunk with an AI just describe make
good games to be fair what the guy said
was this is a Twitter thread that would
semi-viral for negative reasons in Game
Dev as there is one every week yeah
um he said something along the lines of
cyberpunk would have been easier to make
if they could have used AI for all the
low level stuff which is definitely not
how cyberpunk works because but there's
something funny about how like there are
signs in cyberpunk where they like
misspelt night City you're like now
imagine how annoyed you were about that
happening a thousand times
and yes I think I think with like temp
assets Generations yeah you can do stuff
with maps uh but there's a limit there
is a limit to that there is a limit I
think it will be useful as part of the
tool set like for sure I think the
problem so I think it's I think it's
useful for filling in gaps well AI is
brilliant at currently is
skimming all of the output of actual
artists and using that kind of plug gaps
what's interesting is legally that and
ethically arguably that is like dodgy as
[ __ ] like right now there's an
interesting yeah what is it exactly
right now no one owns anything that's
that's the interesting thing is if is
either it exists and there's going to be
there's going to be lore on this and
there isn't currently but my
understanding and the advice I've been
given because obviously every developer
has like look at it and started looking
into like can we use this and stuff
especially those of us who are using IP
and stuff like there is definitely
interesting kind of connections and
stuff
the um but the the advice I've gotten
and the kind of conversations I've heard
basically
um
that
it's it exists right now between one of
two things it's got a bit Wizard of Oz
it's do you believe in the Wizard or do
you believe in the man behind the
curtain if you believe the the Spiel
from these companies that AI is actually
coming up with these images if you
believe that the AI is creatively able
to do that which I I personally don't
but let's say we did then technically uh
an AI can't own anything legally just
like your dog can't own something an AI
can't earn my dog agrees to disagree
exactly right but legally you could you
could uh you you there's there's
precedent interestingly of like animals
can't own copywriting things there's
that famous image of a monkey selfie
where technically that image is owned by
nobody because it was taken by a monkey
yeah it was a camera was stolen there's
a this so camera was stolen by from uh
but from a photographer in The Jungle by
a monkey who took a photo of themselves
and then the guy got the camera back
he took people who were using that photo
to court and said hey that's my picture
of a monkey and legally no it's not a
monkey press the button therefore monkey
owns the picture and his monkeys can't
own anything therefore that picture is
not only human suck man what are we
taking ownership away from monkeys come
on
to be honest
that's the interesting thing so if you
take a if you take it as what what is
being said by the companies that do this
and they certainly would like you they
would try to claim they own it though
right well so that's the interesting so
so if an Aion if an AI made it nobody
owns it if you argue as I would that
actually this is a very complex style of
Montage where you're basically taking a
bunch of other pre-made things mixing
them together
that's legally very dubious because
there's then you're starting to go into
well is it is it parody is it fair use
and anyone who how like how many people
own it then I I again yeah I can only
speak to transformative software it
pertains to YouTube is how I have the
most knowledge on that for obvious
reasons
and I would consider it to be
transformative but
it's a little bit different when it's
transformative for the sole purpose at
least for this particular app of making
money it's not trying to express
something it's not making you're not
commenting on the original art yeah
right and you're selling it as well
you're making that profit from there's a
lot this this stuff legally is gonna
have to it's going to be tested in the
courts because someone will sue because
what's interesting is you the the one
the the image that that kind of to me
kind of shows the illusion of all of
this is there's um there's a very famous
picture I think it's uh a girl in
Afghanistan and if I say you'll know the
image of like it's like a very extreme
close-up of uh like a 12 year old damage
by looking directly down the lens you
know the image if you type into stable
into a lot of these platforms
um Afghan girl close up it will
basically produce that image because
it's the most common result because
that's the because it's such a famous
image and it's been populated it's like
so you if you see that it's like well
then it definitely is is pulling from
that it's not generating it's not got
any concept of what a girl is what
Afghanistan is it's just collating an
image search essentially and and you're
doing that by using Google that's
interesting
um well they would have originally the
data sets they would have basically they
they were scrubbing they probably used
search engines there's a lot of evidence
that deviantART very early on was just
scrubbed for all its content because
that's just obviously a massive
repository of hand-drawn stuff there's
there's lots of stuff and and In
fairness a lot of the early pioneers of
this space because they were you know
technical people who were making
something interesting and it is a very
intellectually interesting cool thing
totally they were very public about what
they were doing they were they were
saying well we're using this because
this is publicly accessible like you
know hackers and coders like will grab
data from wherever it's when it gets to
the stage right now where uh you know
other people are coming in and kind of
commercializing the outcome of that
product right that's where those
questions start to come up but yeah but
like there's definitely the argument
that if this is a hobbyists cool thing
then no problem
it gets very complicated uh I follow
this I guess would be
like a dressmaker on Instagram who'd be
a very small business based in LA
and they put some terms into some AI art
and got dresses and then made them and
it's incredible
um the dresses are so beautiful because
they'll put in like
I guess it's probably like magical fairy
uh dress covered in flowers or something
and then they get the like weird kind of
obscure AR AI art look and make it into
a dress in a stunning and like I'm like
that's a very cool use of this because
it's giving you the concept art but they
actually even
credit a lot of their dresses and say
design in partnership with AI or
whatever because they're not completely
concepting them themselves and I'm like
that's awesome and I also
while I do think everybody dunking on
the idea that cyberpunk would have been
um like they they made it sound like it
would have had way less Dev time or
would have been uh cheaper or without
flaws if they'd used AI art which is
absurd
um there are many cases in which AI is
super helpful for 100 and I actually
don't think that core supposition that
you can do a lot of automated work on
games there's already some amazing like
texture processing we saw a very rough
early version of this with that GTA
remake that came out that I know got a
lot of criticism but that was just like
draft one of that stuff it's very easy
to imagine that's going to get better
that's what the internet told me
but but I think that that's I think
there's room for those tools in the
hands of artists what I didn't like
about their thread was it kind of
implied that you could actually get rid
of the dev team yeah
well but no also like writing and and
you know and there's there's already
there's some good open AR the this open
AI I think people are using to kind of
do uh text and kind of create dialogue
it's it's a nice facsimile it's a cool
illusion but it's not writing like and
it's kind of I read you read the stuff
that it comes up with and you're like
that's really impressive for a computer
but like you wouldn't hire something
about that writing as a sample in there
yeah yeah
um
I've never known of anything having temp
I mean we'd have temp writing in terms
of like this is the first draft of
writing that's made it into this but I
don't know if like
temp right I could see it I could see it
being used for filler I could see a
situation where if you've got like a big
open world game and you want and you've
got like text-to-speech or something and
you just want like just you want anyone
you walk up to in the street to have a
line to say and you just need to
generate 100 basically anything the
stuff this AI I think will initially be
very useful for is low quality high
frequency if you need lots of something
and it doesn't matter if it's [ __ ] you
can get an AI to do it and it will be
relatively successful hey Austin welcome
to the Thunderdome uh we're talking
about Ai and how it's coming for your
job
as well it should
so I actually haven't seen any of the
writing AI stuff
um I've heard of it because I've had
people like oh have you read this
apparently that was like a fake
uh news article written by an AI that
people were talking about but
um AI writing
I think look if these tools make
people's jobs easier
yeah great if it makes things more
efficient so that leads to
um less crunch great that's awesome we
like that um I don't know that's a
reality but that sounds wonderful and
I'm in support of it
um it's the notion that it would take
people's jobs away is something that I
feel like we're concerned about every
10 years in some new way and if it's
possible then it's inevitable ultimately
I think and it's terrifying and terrible
um I definitely do not feel positively
about that
my issue is I think I think games are
incredibly complex machines and I think
a lot of what's currently people getting
excited about Works in isolation like
you can generate three paragraphs of a
bad story and share it and that's very
impressive or you can generate an image
where the hands are a bit wonky but it
looks generally okay once you try and
Slot things together and make like a
game or a movie or a book or you know an
actual unit of you know content or
entertainment I think that's where it
falls down I think it's a really well
raw shark test they'll do the thing
you're talking about where someone will
make an AI game and we'll be like this
is impressive for an AI but as a game
we'll be like it'll be probably pretty
similar to that you could have a full
game made by AI every single Festival
but I don't dance every game developer
every play game developer in the world
will be looking at that game and going
is there anything in this game we can
claim copyright ownership of and can we
sue the makers of it that is a good
point yes every corporation because if
anything in that game looks like Kratos
yeah or you know which it will because
there's a lot of images of I hope that's
not pick on a game here actually worked
yeah
any or yeah
um it's like yeah
yeah the second stuff starts to look
like you know like something that
someone owns then there'll be a really
interesting legal case which I guess
means I certainly don't want to be one
of the people involved in that do they
have to build another AI to then
copyright check the other AI
or does that just have to be done by
hand which means that he's making it
anyway
hasn't I mean that is the that is the
arms race that's what this is what you
just said about the inevitability of an
outcome if it's possible it will happen
and yeah I mean I didn't isn't there
some of that with deep fakes I know like
there's been like there's basically
there's now a really intro well first of
all first of all the way you train an AI
is you create a test for that Ai and
then you have the AI try and beat it
which so intrinsically in an AI process
is a testing process and basically AI is
just constantly trying to it's it's it's
it's uh adversarial it's trying to kind
of uh trick itself
but then you also now do get like there
are deep fake detecting AIS because just
to do exactly what you're saying of like
trying to skim and find that data what's
interesting again is because an AI
doesn't fundamentally have any
understanding
of what it's looking at because it's not
got a you know holistic human mind
um you get very weird false positives so
there's there's lots of really good
examples of this in terms of well not
good examples terrible examples of this
from like a racism point of view where
AI is if you write into most of these
ai's untrustworthy person it's not going
to show you a white guy and there's
stuff like that where it's kind of
rebuilding and and well the Google
search is racist it's the it's repeating
what the data set had seen has provided
you know well yeah and I mean that's an
interesting thing again if you Google
unprofessional hairstyle it'll give you
a bunch of pictures of black women yeah
um and you can be like well the
algorithm is a racist well it's if it's
it's curated by a bunch of individual
humans then yeah it kind of is
it's almost like systemic racism is a
real thing and we should look to address
it um anyway as a podcast full of white
people I don't know about that yeah yeah
we're down to conception but I do think
there is like there's an interesting
because the point I'm making is that the
AI is is very cool and very clever but
it's also phenomenally stupid it will
just basically Echo whatever patterns
there was an interesting thing um an
interesting discussion on the art side I
think a couple of weeks ago where you
know people were noticing that they were
like uh leftovers of signatures on
artwork like are you seeing some of that
and there's kind of two schools of
thought there one is yeah it's just
showing itself too easily the other is
the AI is so stupid that it thinks in
order for something to look like good
art it has to have a little squiggle in
the corner and is that kind of like
again it's not this isn't this isn't
something holistically intelligent this
is something that's learning pattern
recognition at a ridiculous level and
you can get very pretentious about that
and go oh well all humans are matches
it's like yes but you know what a dog is
you know what I mean like you have
concept of a world outside the data set
you're probably presenting
um I'm sure I've said this on this show
before I uh and
if I haven't incredible
um I took a tour of uh what used to be
like an old porn studio and they were
telling us about
um butthole recognition AI
where they had an AI that would Auto
detect a fingerprint an anus and lighten
it so they were Auto bleaching buttholes
via AI as a post-process oh that's
awesome in post
yeah like years ago too this is a long
time ago to end because otherwise people
at work light and buttholes frame by
frame can you imagine goodbye to
monetization by the way
um that was fun while it lasted but like
that's awesome that's fascinating 22
minutes in we're okay you can't do it oh
I held my pothole
23 minutes
yeah so um like I think they're probably
AI Technologies like the record I am 99
sure that you have not told that story
before no I think that is the original
playlist in concert we just we just
achieved that that's amazing that kind
of AI is making a very tedious job for a
human a lot easier and it isn't actually
hurting any artist unless one of the
stars did not work and you could make
the argument that it is empowering the
artists within the porn industry to do
other things right like that's I think
I've said this on the show before my
first job in the industry is a button
that takes 1.2 milliseconds in unity now
like that's ridiculous like that's the
same you've said that before you lose
the job I just got to do more
interesting stuff yeah I don't think
I've never actually said what that
button I think job was or at least I
don't remember I remember very much this
it's now a thing you click in unity but
what was the actual task so it is a
weirdly rudimentary AI very like AI in a
completely different sense to what
people now mean by it but basically
there's a thing there's a thing in
computer games called nav meshes so when
you're so where a character can't just
you know just drop a character into a
world and they could just run wherever
you have to kind of Define where the
areas they can run to are right and it
used to be in the day uh muggins like me
would get hired to sit in a corner and
by hand place the mesh on the
environment of where the characters can
go and then you know you you have
somewhere for your AI to run around and
there'd be bugs and those bugs they come
back to you and whatever now what
happens is uh the uh most game engines
all game engine engines realistically I
think at this point have now from s
generation where they'll look at the
environment and you'll set some rules of
like what constitutes a staircase versus
a drop what constitutes a safe space how
big a area should does what's this width
of the character to get through a
doorway and it'll just generate
that nav mesh which is a form of AI it's
basically kind of going through the
level and building that out this is this
is
um it's just a job for entry-level
idiots like me at the age of 21. also I
was going to ask has there been any I'll
let you speak first but has there been
any facet of your job that since you've
been in the industry has gotten Easier
by virtue of some kind of automation or
AI
um
control F makes my job a lot easier
I mean there are a million
things that are modern software
especially Daws digital audio
workstation like Cubase Pro Tools logic
digital performer Ableton
etc etc the software that composers use
to write is loaded with features that
make life orders of magnitude faster and
more efficient and easier and a lot of
tasks there are there are still like for
example the the task of preparing sheet
music if I if I play in a piano part on
my you know keyboard into the computer
and it sounds back as a piano because I
have a piano VST virtual instrument
enabled
if I want to put that if I want to
create sheet music from that and put it
in front of a real pianist
the software makes that a million times
faster than it was but it's still pretty
labor intensive because music notation
is a very subjective
um
uh sort of format it's people would
assume can't I just I get asked this all
the time can't I just isn't there an app
where I can just sing into my phone and
it'll show me the sheet music and it's
like
if you define a bunch of parameters like
exactly what your Tempo is and things
like that then that theoretically uh we
we could we could get pretty close to
that also you have a friend of mine
built a pretty slick thing called
imitone which lets you sing into like
your like USB microphone and it will
essentially like he used it as a way to
drive VST so you could essentially like
jam on a synth trumpet with your voice
uh or whatever which is pretty slick but
one of the things that he did that was
pretty smart was he kind of quantized
the octave to you can set a scale
because obviously another challenge with
the idea of to your exact point the the
software can be very smart and at the
same time very stupid if I sing you know
uh
you know what I'm singing you've heard
it before the Die Hard team tune
um I can sing it pretty Out Of Tune like
wildly so and it's the equivalent of of
reading a sentence that's just a wash in
typos and us like a like a a human
immediately means yeah you don't have to
be particularly clever with language or
anything to be able to parse enormous
amounts of grammatical and spelling
errors and or in things that are defy
convention same with music whereas the
software is going to say oh well
assuming an a440 tuning scheme and like
um you know just intonation then uh what
you actually saying is 73 hundredths of
a half step shy of G followed by and
like yeah it's going to give you this
thing that's so accurate that it misses
the force for the trees you know what I
mean so you need uh currently there are
there are tools that are kind of getting
smarter about trying to recognize
intention like actually it amazes me the
software I use now I can I can quickly
spin off I just had this this week I had
a flute player come over here and some I
had had my assistant make like an actual
part based of like actual sheet music
done properly formatted nicely so it
actually looks pretty and I had on the
iPad for her to read read and then I
realized I had accidentally not included
a section so I said just give me a
second and I run the little script in my
software but it's ugly as all hell you
know it's like the thing notices for
example that I that I if I lift the note
off just ever so slightly early instead
of a note that looks like this you get a
note that looks like
you know
uh
uh audio listen playlist listen first
Austin appears to be riding with a pen
and paper
yeah I could have done it better
way better okay
well like if it's just if it's just hold
a note the top one is the intention but
if I hold the note ever so not like if I
if I if I let off ever so slightly early
then the system is going to try to draw
a note of the exact length which is very
cumbersome to look at and and so that's
what's sorry no no that's that's a
perfect example of like
comparatively though it's way less crude
than it used to be it's actually gotten
really smart at recognizing intention
and and making sort of smart guesses
um and so that's such a way
I'm excited because you're you're going
into something which all the coders
watching are screaming fuzzy logic at
the screen which is just a really
interesting aspect that I think AI has
has kind of normalized or done something
with is is pro computers are very bad at
dealing with vagueness or or actually
thinking with vaginously something you
don't really think about humans are very
good at it's kind of beautiful if it is
beautiful Austin you know Austin holds a
long note any other composer listening
they're not gonna they're gonna lean
over to them and ask did you mean one of
these five formations they're gonna say
oh you're you're doing that yeah and and
Computing has all it's actually been a
real challenge over the last couple of
decades in Computing of how do you make
a computer program fuzzy enough that it
can make a good choice and you have
fuzzy logic which was which is used uh
or I think was pioneered for um optical
character recognition So reading text
reading handwriting reading stuff like
that where essentially the computer goes
what's a zero kind of look like and kind
of but that's a very hard thing to
Define implications to the cars in like
Forza and Gran Turismo as well I believe
because if they don't have imperfections
even if it's like a scratch or a hint of
dust it makes them look less realistic
so they had to add the Apollo 11 dirty
rocking exactly Sorry probably 13 Dirty
rocket but but it works the other way is
computers can't interpret stuff that's
messy and dirty and Scratchy and that's
one of the things that's been a big
driver towards this current approach to
AI is if you want computers to be able
to see a car so to use your example in
Reverse
um which that people do because we want
self-driving cars and all that stuff
um you have to make a computer
understand that a car is still a car
even if it's dusty and Scratchy and the
way a lot of these AIS work
stable diffusion you've probably heard
the phrase and that specifically is
basically it's kind of if it's trying to
make you know Alana but painted in the
style of Picasso what it will do is it
will take the photo of you it'll
actually massively blur that photo and
then try and work back in the detail in
that kind of fuzzy way because computers
really struggle
it's taken a lot of work and a lot of
kind of clever Thinking by people to
define a to teach AIS and to make AIS
think in a vague generalized way so you
can go
that's a car even if the car is Dusty or
rotated 45 degrees or a different color
than they're expecting well then think
about our threshold for identification
like a car that has been smashed to
pieces in an accident and it has all
kinds of parts missing and and is
mangled and bent into crude angles even
a child would have absolutely no
challenge in recognizing and and it's
interesting how about a toy car right if
you look at a photo of a toy car versus
a real car like what do you know you
look at that you know oh that's a talk
that's a Hot Wheels or that's a real car
but could you define what the difference
is that you're spotting the noticing and
making a computer again like understand
those those vaguenesses it's I mean it's
all the [ __ ] that they did in the Next
Generation with [ __ ] data right like
but the the complexities of the human
the experiencing thing about um to make
our first Star Wars reference and or
they actually do have some of the like
map painting backgrounds in that show
and they stand out as not looking as
good as they did because now we have the
ability to tell that it's a map painting
because it's such high fidelity so you
can tell it's a matte painting in ways
that you used to not necessarily be able
to detect and that's the thing that I
feel like I could not explain to an AI I
feel like is this a CGI background in
matte painting or is it real and now I
can go oh that's a painting for sure
where but that's that's the genius and
that's the genius of the kind of this
drawing from a massive pool is you don't
have to explain to a computer what the
difference is now a computer can look at
every map painting that was ever painted
and learn that stuff itself yeah and
that's that's where it gets that's both
very cool and obviously very kind of
intimidating or challenge especially
challenging legally and yeah
I generate stuff and yeah I mean look
we've had this conversation so recently
I'm sorry we're having the same
conversation again everybody
um but it is you know something that is
affected a lot of people or a lot of
people are interested in at the very
least
um to discuss as it evolves I'm
interested I'm very interested to see
how it develops legally because I don't
know what
what the correct answer I know what I
feel ethically is that I think it is is
theft effectively
um at least the case of art just
stealing other art
um
but I don't I don't know how the
boardroom of all people in suits is
going to figure that out I feel like
it's going to be a mess but I'm very
interested to see what happens and how
the conversation evolves and you know I
don't think automation is negative
across the board I think there are
advantages as to what you're saying
there for both of you really it makes
your jobs easier it didn't take your job
away or someone else's job away
necessarily no but it but and that's and
that's interesting right because in
theory the way this is all meant to work
is we all have to work less because the
the computers make our lives easier but
unfortunately when you look at the
examples of like factories basically
what automation came for first like
factories retail you know those kind of
lower skilled jobs it's not like it made
those jobs any easier it actually kind
of it decreased those jobs and and their
hours basically stay the same for us
it's never going to make our jobs easier
it's always just going to give us more
time for other work
but the point is under capitalism to
continue down the threat I've been on
this whole episode like under capitalism
they will optimize that out like we
don't you don't walk into a shop and see
a bunch of more relaxed creative retail
assistants looking for exciting new ways
to enhance the business you see half the
staff because of the automation going on
with the with with the self-service
checkout system I notices Less in
America like in the UK like oh they're
everywhere here self-service is it's all
over Houston's open Home self-service
checkouts
um yeah
the just playing pentament just finished
playing uh pentament a few weeks ago and
again loved it but that a lot of that
game is set in a scriptorium
which um
basically just rich people in Bavaria
were paying people in a scriptorium to
scribe books for them and create artwork
and that's the thing I didn't even
really know existed like I understood
conceptually but seeing it play out in a
video game I was like I guess was that
like a commercialization of what was
going on within the church they
basically had they created like a prize
so the church would do that for rich
people yeah rich people would approach
the church and there would be artists
and uh I guess scribes I don't really
know if that's what they're called in
the scriptorium who they would approach
um yeah to make books for them and
create certain artworks for them uh and
it's funny how throughout history The
Church and commerce has kind of because
then you later you know in the
Renaissance you have the church paying
artists to produce great artworks for
them and it's like but it's weird how
the power of church has kind of moved
kind of up and down that's been a very
interesting church history that's very
interesting
um they do such a good job of
everybody's religious including the
characters you play there's a lot of God
bless yous and thank the Lord for this
winter but it never feels preachy in
either direction as an atheist it never
felt like I was being bridged at and I
also feel like
um any Christians watching would also
feel completely at home when we summon
Troy Baker any Christians watching we
did you said the word Christian hello
um yeah they did really really good job
of that it would have been it must have
been really hard but it is I think that
was just the reality of the time right
the atheism was like a luxury that very
few people could yeah I mean it
technically criticizes the church but I
don't know that it would be taken poorly
I'm really not sure I'm talking about
pentiments
yeah it's the equivalent of saying you
know Bloody Mary three times we we talk
about I said Church three times to show
up yeah like yeah like the idea churches
employing artists and and uh and you you
were like in the middle of a session and
then suddenly you just warped out of it
and don't know what
that's why I said how the [ __ ] are you
troyed
I just now pressed record I I want to
know what this is all about for sure but
I to just kick everything off I don't
understand why specifically with Windows
great AI if
foreign
[Laughter]
if I don't turn my computer on for like
two weeks hmm
nothing works and I appreciate that
Austin will get this joke more than
anyone it's almost like the night in
Last Crusade was like I knew you would
come and it's you have all of the
updates that are needed yeah nothing
works anymore it just it was it was like
as if I had opened it oh my God I don't
think I've ever left my PC off for two
weeks
but
[Music]
yeah I've been gone yeah they've been
here yeah that's fair but I am rather
centered
like centered emotionally I mean like
cinematography graphically or like in
terms of yeah like like my my framing
yeah it's beautiful yes I'm really
letting the team down today
are you at an undisclosed location I'm
in Australia and again
no no this is this is my parents place
is a lot of Hotel they got that they
stole that from a hotel they have a sign
outside but I've been meaning to talk to
my mom about that's that says something
like
like the beach called to me or something
like that like it's some really just so
cheesy like I'm on beach time type of
sign I'm gonna be like Mom we need to
talk about that word we've really got to
talk about it
that she's otherwise gone she has 18 I
think bonsais
big fan of bonsai is growing around
trimming them back that's almost a real
tree wait I don't understand so we could
have 18. I thought you're only like not
loud legally
my thing is she has to water them daily
how the [ __ ] man
I've killed several bonsai trees bonsais
do you have in here it is a lot they're
beautiful but I would never because it's
way too many goddamn size automated
plants search this house I've gone for
three weeks and I'm worried about my
plants dying and I was like I don't know
what the solution to that is I guess
they just die I put gloves on are you
kidding me no first of all they have I
use them I use them but I don't think
it's gonna be long enough
for the ferns that need to be watered
every three years
there are human beings
Nature's gone any friend any friend that
you're like hey would you come in and
um would you uh please water my plants
any person that says yes to that
you got one in your house
they are going through all your [ __ ]
they're like yeah I would love to do
that absolutely shouldn't have said that
from patreon
you get to come into my house
just one plant though
nope nope nope nope nope I have 30. I
did have a stent dog sitting for a
friend every time he would leave town
for many years uh dog sitting is
different yeah I agree
there was not uh it was it was quite
imposing though I I would have to
basically move into his place for like a
week and a half uh and it was good to
know the dog become familiar with it
no I mean one of my closest friends but
still it was like a big on every every
year would entail going over to that
play two huge dogs
um that sounds great still sounds good
oh I mean I enjoyed it he he lived right
at the entrance of Runyon Canyon so I
would take the dogs up to the top of the
canyon every morning and you know what
you can automate dog food now they have
a automated uh dog feeders and water
bowls that that dispense more water so
that the dogs can eat
yes however those are people that should
not have dogs I don't know what happens
if the power goes out though as well
like there you go like good point or
something goes wrong I never trust I
would never trust a piece of technology
to keep we uh keep them alive no I think
it's just to uh to we'll help them when
you're when you're out for a day I don't
think it's to keep the dog alive oh for
like a day oh yeah fair enough because
yeah that's 24 hours they'll have a deal
with Netflix exactly the second the dogs
realize that they can automate us out
the process Alana we're done self-aware
it's not true they love us I think
Terminator was wrong
I had asked Austin if there are facets
of his job that have become easier as a
result of AI like positive things is
there anything let's get into that dude
that is easier as a result of AI rather
than like it replacing you or whatever
I would have to probably consult with
people that deal with all of my [ __ ]
on the back end right
because AI really input is still kind of
analog yeah
um for for what I do there is however
about the directing side of things that
you do
yeah yeah it's all manual it's all about
what we do with the stuff that we're
making then
like that's why I really don't
have I I don't do Trends I really don't
but I was like
this is interesting the lens the whole
linza thing
and is that the name of the app that's
the app oh okay yeah and I was like oh
this is fun uh you got me you got me to
spend five bucks or whatever on you and
I have some
fan fiction pictures of myself now
um you surely didn't have any of those
otherwise
surely you have fan art surely there are
people it was it was remarkable how
similar it was to mine
um
yeah
wow one to one it's looking in the
mirror it just stole his art and sold it
back yeah I was like hey you son of a
[ __ ] there's so much art of Troy Baker
on the internet but I made some money
off of it that I spent myself
um but this is the thing and like like
my wife is a photographer and
um
uh as we have seen like that the number
one thing that every time they come out
with a new
iPhone I can't wait to burp through this
entire thing this is not an endorsement
but I really love this
it's this great kombucha that doesn't
have any sugar really in it
um and I believe in good gut health so
I've been drinking this but Lord
Almighty I'll shake the rafters up and
down or what are you talking about up
and down yeah up and down
um I've I've vertigo
um that was a visual joke for your spot
it wasn't a good one no it was a joke
that existed enough
but uh and I apologize
um the thing that about that whole app
with Lindsay was like this is an
interesting thing to show
um to me how much it's off
um because like my wife is a
photographer and if you look the um the
number one thing they talk about with
every whatever time they come out of the
new iPhone or new Galaxy or new iPad or
a new Apple product or new no one talks
about the Galaxy
um is the phone or is it not the same
they never talk about the phone they
talk about the camera yeah they talk
about how great the camera is and that
it's got a gajillion megapixels and and
knits and whatever the [ __ ] they're
pushing and they talk about how you
could shoot a movie now on this thing
brightness no you can't no you can't
um and if you ever were to there's some
stuff that I've shot I was like wow it
looks really really good if you put that
up against shooting that on an Alexa or
an Ari mini LF or whatever you will see
the difference and it will be apparent
not only that but even with that camera
I can put the best camera
in the hands of someone who's untrained
and it'll look like [ __ ] and not only
that but even when you do have the best
cinematographer then you need people in
the back end to be able to color time
that and actually make sure that that
looks cohesive without the entire thing
and there's actually a feeling that
there's a color palette to it as opposed
to just what went in raw natively in the
camera color grading classes to learn to
color grade because it's extremely hard
and it's it's been a month and a half
and it's still really [ __ ] hard and
let me tell you hey I can't color grade
that said the those new cameras are
beautiful and I like obviously uh you
were you would agree with this so I just
want to say it for the sake of saying it
is
um the new cameras are doing an
incredible job and it is a cool
opportunity for anyone at home who wants
to like try making something totally
make your own short film on an iPhone
camera and that's rad but it's not going
to look Cinema quality it's not possible
well ironically as well there's a lot of
AI now being used to make your photos on
iPhone look better yeah the automation
of that stuff before your update has
like a bypass it's like it has like a a
layer that you can layer and it's really
good it's super there's layers you don't
even know like there's there's layers to
the toilet mode how that camera does
stuff yeah but I love it like just the
raw if you just take a vanilla photo and
iPhone there is a degree of
post-processing that's been done already
on the image that's come through just
because they know they can cover for
your mistakes basically yeah all the
mistakes at the point to that point
Alana is that what I do love is that
never before has it been easier as a
Creator to make something right and have
it be something that is palatable Austin
can speak to this for sure the number
one thing that anybody who if you you
ever do a short the number one thing
they tell you do not skimp on is audio
and the fact that there it is a hundred
bucks
can get you an amazing sounding
microphone to be able to capture the
dialogue you need for your film or
wherever you're short or for your
animated thing or for whatever it's it's
incredible what's available so I'm not
I'm not I think I take very seriously
never criticized for my audio at all
I I think that it's there's never been a
better time to create I just don't think
that I'm not scared of AI and maybe I'm
naive but I just don't think that it's
like if if I can be replaced I probably
should be then that means that there's
something else that I need to do because
nothing that I do is going to prevent
that from happening no I said that early
in the answer mine was if it is possible
it is inevitable effectively if we can
be replacing I don't know that I agree
with you sure but we will be I do think
that that is true if if we can be we
will be and it's inevitable in this
absolutely nothing we can do about it
okay just just you you have to adapt
like if someone would have 20 years ago
hear this podcast they'd be like I'm
sorry what the account you're talking
about the Steven Spielberg movie
to start with
um the uh one thing that's interesting
to me and you were already starting to
see
um and this happens with with every
major technology or technological
breakthrough is essentially like
aesthetic uh Styles kind of being
associated with it or or impacting the
way Aesthetics work so the question I've
got is
theoretically what's really interesting
is there's now this weird thing which I
think I've been predicting on this show
for a while and I think it's this AI is
the next step in this where basically
it's getting cheaper than ever to make
something photo real or much cheaper
than ever to make something that is that
is hyper detailed in that way
um and and
what's interesting to me about that is
and I guess this this I I see this
coming potentially for the voice over
side of things as well is I wonder if
once people start to get used to AI
generated voices if I wonder if Troy's
ever going to be in the booth recording
then a director is going to say could
you just put a bit more AI spin on that
for me and we'll end up in a situation
where I wonder if there's actually going
to be like the influence of this stuff
we're actually starting to come into the
so that creative humans are basically
being like emulating or being inspired
by the Aesthetics that are going to
arise out there's an analogy to that
that's already very common which is
especially in the kind of Blockbuster
Big epic sound the trailer music thing
uh sample libraries routinely are
they're so produced that if you're going
for a thing that sounds super huge and
gigantic a real Orchestra even a huge
Orchestra doesn't quite sound the same
as the way the samples do and so even on
a production you know like a Hans Zimmer
production where there is basically no
limitation on what you can spend in
terms of number of musicians how many
days in the studio et cetera et cetera
they are still routinely adding in the
samples because
it adds an aesthetic that a 100 live
Orchestra
uh takes away from and that the taste
The Taste has become so accustomed to
the sound of certain kinds of sounds
that they become folded into it as a
result that's exactly that's exactly
it's not AI but it's kind of a proxy of
a similar idea that there's a thing that
is artificial that that is that people
go can't this sound more like that
mythical argument on that I just think
that's really fascinating that's just
intriguing from like a creative point of
view that's happening I mean I joked
about this earlier but the the part of
my job that technically AI makes
infinitely easier and yet I still find
it tedious is Ctrl f
having to find something that was
departure in Ragnarok where I had to
like look through all the scripts and
find every reference to like father or
something the white boy I had done that
before just out of curiosity 13 million
instances
named boy for a very long time they
didn't have a name so he was just boy in
the scripts just uh very funny to read
because they still exist
um but yeah it was like control effing
to find
um something and it's still you know you
get a hundred results or whatever but
you can tab through them the thought of
having to do that without Ctrl F could
have taken me months for something that
ended up taking like two days like that
is are you guys tremendous amount of
work that a robot helped me do way way
faster
are you hip to what is this program
called
uh um the answer is almost definitely oh
it's it's a writing it's a writing
program part of that yes
misses it's Miss word Miss word
um there is a
damn it I'm gonna find it real quick
because I get now I get emails from it's
like Pro writer or something like that
or or uh writers
Celtics Final Cut Pro sorry
um God almighty there is there is a a
program that basically will analyze what
regardless of you inputs like this is a
script this is a uh resume letter and it
will literally audit and grade your
[Music]
um
the writing style it will show you where
you can improve
um I use Metacritic myself
that's after the fact I
know it's interesting and
I believe it to be trustworthy
um I I haven't used it yet I was just
curious if you guys have seen this but
it's it became highly recommended
um
what the [ __ ] is it called man
that's interesting it's like similar
though to like the person who uses like
a thesaurus to like find fancy awards
for things does it kind of trigger that
kind of behavior is it I assume it's
smarter than that did that so much I had
a mate who did he did a spell check on
his one of his history essays and he
didn't bother like Jack he just went
with the first suggestion and the
teacher stood in front of class and read
out the entire essay it was it was
called the re-evaluation of presence in
Prussia and it was just here yes
it was just like
wow Pro writing Aid
um it is something that is
um One account 150 hours of writing
training so that what they do is they
have like a tool but then they also have
like they're a platform for Learning and
becoming a better writer interesting so
I I think that there's Merit to that
because not everybody can go to USC look
I I just got
um but who gets to Define what's good
writing in that equation
I just had the opportunity to just to um
I I dabble in writing because I want to
understand the process of it I don't
consider myself a writer but I do want
to be able to speak to it and I feel
like if I'm ever going to critique
anything or or try to adjust it I better
know what it's like to have sat down and
actually wrote something so that I know
what I'm asking
um and and and through that I've I've
developed like I was like I like writing
out ideas and seeing how it's possible
what'd you say you just had a joke that
I missed she's an [ __ ] ignore that
all right if she she needs someone to
come in and artificially bleach uh
no you said um you said wrote um and I
said it would be written um based on the
context of the of the conversation
something that I wrote um no you want
you said you wanted to have sit down and
wrote
I said it would be written so I was
giving you an AI correction it doesn't
matter at all
I need you to know as your friend I was
laughing at her not you in my room
because that was a [ __ ] dick move
dick move I'm down for dick moves
so I I sent off this thing to Craig
Mason I was like hey dude I'm gonna I'm
gonna pull a friend card and go will you
read this and tell me what you think and
he says do you want light medium or
extra crispy and I was like I want extra
crispy because I don't learn from
lighter medium he's like okay that means
I'm I'm going to critique this as if
it's something that I wrote and a couple
weeks went by and he texted me while I
was on the train uh with Austin and and
Andrea uh from Milan to Venice he goes
you free and I went yeah I got 15
minutes an hour and a half later
just goes I'll be right back and stepped
and went and sat away and then
not a single one of them was was this
kind of like uh to taste I don't really
like this it was like let me it goes I
think you have something here it's
really good
but I oh I just have my biggest problem
is you're with your fundamental premise
I was like oh okay just that because if
you can solve that problem I think
you're onto something but nothing is
ever going to let me tell you everybody
who thinks that they can write like you
know you go to university for it and do
it for 10 years but uh everybody so if
you didn't respect the work if you
didn't respect the work you wouldn't
have given you two minutes
relationship alone is what is what got
me that audience for sure and feedback
still I think you'd have gotten a polite
that's interesting I think I think if he
hadn't had any respect for what you've
given him I don't think you'd have had
an hour and a half conversation
I agree with that as well I also think
that I look at looking at someone like
Craig who is so passionate about writing
and
I I had to put myself in a different
mindset because I asked someone times
like do you have any I need something to
direct do you have anything you're just
not got any Scripture you're not going
to use he goes no do you think I just
write for fun
I do I never thought about that and he
goes but here's the difference anything
that he's going to write
where he's at now
is going to get made
so is this the thing that he wants to
make because if he goes here's my show I
mean I guess it's a full-time job I've
written two screenplays a one and a half
at least and I have no intention of ever
giving them to anybody because I wrote
them for fun right that's it different
space most people don't most people
think he popped up on Chernobyl this
guy's been writing for decades like he's
been on everything so he's at the point
now where he's like now this is what I
do this is my life
yes but but it's more than just his job
it's like his purpose for being here and
once you achieve that level where it's
like if I sit down and I write something
I go here someone Netflix Amazon HBO
someone's gonna snatch that up and turn
it into four series four seasons of
television
so he's like uh Jesus Christ I'm not
gonna just sit down and haphazardly
write something so I think that's what
he also is like I love talking about
this I love the critique I love the
process I love teaching he's a very much
of a teaching Spirit but I that's that's
something that no
app or website can can change like no
one can give you that years of
experience and I also don't think a
website or an app
can give you the critique in a helpful
way because part of it editing writers
um which I've done
for almost as long as I've been a writer
is knowing how to give actionable
feedback to an individual person you
have to give the feedback based on who
the person you're giving the feedback to
because you know how they'll understand
things you know who they are you
understand even sensitivities that's
part of editing is you have to like make
sure that you're conveying why the edit
exists for some people and AI is never
going to be able to do that there is a
world where I do believe writing could
make people less interested in right
I do believe that the dispassionate
Nature by which that is dispensed can be
very helpful because sometimes when
someone goes
um it was like oh what if there's too
much emotion that's put into that if
there's too much sensitivity put into it
as opposed to
that's the lesson I had to learn this
director for sure like I was 100 like
taking it very personally whenever I
give negative feedback to someone yeah
that's definitely Craig was like oh no
this is bad you shouldn't do this let me
tell you why that's the other thing is
like like how would how would a um an AI
rate a Coen Brothers script
an AI is not going to learn know the
premise or theme of a piece of written
work for first style but not only is
that it's not even premise or theme it's
just the Styles like oh the sentence is
too short you know yeah or this
character doesn't speak enough like if
you well you said growth when you meant
written
the dumbest program in the world could
make that observation
like if you gave dumbest piece of
program I kind of want to try it I I
don't know what these programs are but I
kind of want to try and get a bunch of
like like what it What would an AI think
of Black Swan or mother oh yeah it'd be
like uh what the hell is this it doesn't
make any sense garbage or as much as I
don't like Pulp Fiction you know what I
mean like it's something that is super
stylized dialogue is it Royale with
cheese
Jesus you mispronounced this word it is
Royal you spelled it incorrectly
um 50 of Americans misspell this word
the thing the thing though is is also I
do believe that it is a helpful tool but
right it is not it is not if even even a
Craig Mason is not going to make me a
writer it's it's it's not going to
produce a good script
I will be able to learn some things that
I didn't know before
and the joy that I have right now is
going back to something that I thought
was pretty finished I was like I think
this is pretty good to go
no it's like not at all man so I think
that there's there's all I I think it's
a yes and I think A.I and coaches and
classes and doing it that's amazing
because I think I've been supportive and
assistive tool and the more accessible
creating stuff gets the better across
the board there are a lot of AI uses for
disabled people of various disabilities
and that's [ __ ] awesome
um the more of that we can get the
better I think the commercial aspect of
the
the art that that app that we've been
talking about I feel like I'm not
comfortable with it
um and I had like I said earlier just
interested to see how the law actually
deals with it question mark who's got
the barking dog is that you Troy it's
100 8-bit that I just don't understand
the most affable go for it no he's not I
think he's like his eyesight is going
how old is like He barked at me though
that he's 10. oh sorry man
[Music]
um
Ronan came over the other day and Travis
and Laura's son and he and traveler like
two months apart and traveler has like a
Darth Vader mask and so rona's like I
want to put that on and eight bit was
like no I don't know what you are you're
a weird shape I have like three before
we goes that I would love to do this
episode I was gonna do I've watched half
of Vandal I was thinking about doing
Austin you also played immortality but
I've decided to go with Troy The Last of
Us trailer is so good
but
all right dear God
um I I really have to give it to Craig
and Neil because that is one of the best
and people don't even realize I think
necessarily how good it is but you will
after you've seen the show because what
they condensed into two and a half
minutes
was the entire show
they they set up the characters the
world the tone expectations
um
they put everybody on display
and it's just I've seen up to episode
five and
I can tell you right now
you get to episode three
you're done
that you're you you are standing on your
desk Oh Captain My Captain
um because it is what it sets up in the
first two episodes it it introduces you
to the world if you have no idea what it
is it takes all of your expectations and
just
like do you have like a weird
like because your relationship to that
interesting because like it's you have
so much ownership over that character in
that Universe really
yeah but so you know I really appreciate
a lot of people have been
very vocal about you know their support
everything and like there's only one
Joel for me and I'm like I hope not God
I hope not if that's the truth then we
all failed to create a character it has
to be bigger than us and that's that's
the Beauties I Pedro and I were
backstage of the game awards it would be
like a musician writing a song that that
should never get a cover you know like
it's like this that's like the Hallmark
that you've written a good piece of
music if someone can change their own
yeah like there's and not only that but
also it's like I kind of like this
version better it's like yeah that if if
the song is made better by by
interpretation that is a great song that
is an amazing if it can be done
with
strings an acoustic guitar acapella
reggae it's like that's a great song you
you made something that is to be fair
you were describing one version that was
all the ingredients of your ideal I was
just thinking I'd love to see them metal
[Laughter]
um but telling being able to tell Pedro
was like he said something goes your DNA
is is inextricably tied with our
performance and I said well what you
we're just fawning all over each other
and I said well what you proved is that
this character is bigger than any one
performance
it's very sweet um man it's also earned
and God damn Bella Ramsey
[ __ ] you don't people don't even know
she is coming for you she is so
effortless that's terrifying it is she
is terrifying like instantly she would
hide you right now
you're dead it's already done
um the thing that Pedro like you can you
can see pedry like ah got it I see him
in that role
um what you don't get
with knowing anything about Bella Ramsey
is
the 15 000 layers of [ __ ] that's
happening underneath every choice yeah
and
there was there was a physicality that I
feel I'm inspired by Pedro's
performances Joel that's awesome
um I I wish that I could go back and do
some things different should we just get
all the spoilers most of us too you're
going to be in loss of us three right
Troy
I'm gonna skip three they'll do a lot of
7.2 where they redo the performances in
10 years yes like Kingdom Hearts yeah
yeah and it'll be Pedro I was like you
get into this suit [ __ ] yeah I
just thought you'd deal with that I had
this thing away with a lot of media like
I I really think the last of us is just
so like perfect in a way that I wouldn't
change anything so initially my reaction
to TV show was why do I need this you
but you did it and it's why why do we
need more and then watching the trailer
did you ever listen to like
um
this is the shittiest example I'm trying
to give a better better version of this
but
um
and hey I could probably come up with on
the way to I believe someone's gonna
fact check this and please feel free to
correct me but on the way to
either the Grammys or the MTV Music
Awards
um disparate members of Bon Jovi got
stuck somewhere the only two they were
able to be there for their performance
was John Bon Jovi and Rich de Sambora
and they're like what do we do we've got
this Hit album that we're supposed to
perform and so Richie Sambora goes I got
an acoustic and they're like you want to
go out on stage in front of millions of
people watching and everybody that's
there in attendance
for the year being the new glam metal
band or whatever we're gonna call you
and you want to perform acoustic
and that performance was so successful
it started the MTV Unplugged wow and
then we have every other iteration of
some of the most I mean like tears from
heaven for Eric Clapton the Layla was
like that's the pre eminent version that
everybody knows now more than the Derek
of the Domino's version so my what I'm
saying is that
Bon Jovi was really cool
um
there is there is something that
inherently happens when you go I don't
need a better version of that it's like
have you ever imagined it like this what
if you didn't have these constraints
stuck in traffic yeah I think he's
calling you out for a failure of
imagination Alana as well even I feel
bad having seen having seen the um oh
it's a garage door uh freak me out I was
like oh quick Bella Ramsay appeared in
that [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
it still was fast though uh watching the
channel
you should handle your Terror very well
well it's because
I'm too used to L.A and I was like oh we
don't have those here I don't need to
there's no fault line here I don't need
to worry about that yes you're not still
scared of earthquakes are you oh yeah
let's get a [ __ ] out of me
okay let me tell you to just to add
another side note to this like on a
scale from kitten to Bella Ramsay where
do you put a couple back asleep so that
they're like I'm more scared of Bella
Ramsey now
um but like I mean that's just
calibration
uh no I like I can't fall back asleep
there is one but um yeah dude I've seen
so many coyotes on the street recently
just walking around
um and I don't I don't have the know-how
I could tell you what to do with a snake
or a spider I don't know what to do
about a coyote what do you mean what am
I supposed to be scared you just yelling
make noise they're so easily scared okay
yeah a lot of them follow that would
they would they it's like a fox is about
the same size as a fox okay it's very
skinny they're big enough yeah they're
like they're like medium dog size I
think my dog's a little bit whatever
them followed us would they ever attack
a person unless they yes this is a story
recently about if coyote pulled a little
girl out of the back of a [ __ ] car
Austin the child maybe uh like something
that they'll clock as easy pickings but
an adult I'm worried about it okay
before you continue down the joking part
I could believe the child is okay yes
child is okay child was raised by them
TNT you've got to worry about with the
coyotes
Bella Ramsay
that's better